Inner Mongolia is China’s Montana.
Its winters are cold, its summers, hot, and
its wide open spaces isolated and unforgiving.
…Which makes it a very strange place to
build a giant 200-foot-tall red Victorian
palace.
Sure, the rich and famous have been known
to make some… unorthodox architectural decisions.
But way out here near the Gobi desert, you
won’t find any tennis courts, golf clubs,
or art museums…
nevermind a Trader Joe’s.
In fact, the only amenities include a highway
interchange to nowhere, a non-functional airstrip,
and an Indiana Jones-style cardboard-cutout
city.
This place was never meant to be lived in.
It was built as target practice, on China’s
largest military base.
And the People’s Liberation Army clearly
had a very specific mission in mind.
This is that 200-foot-tall palace in the desert.
And this is Taiwan’s Presidential Office
Building in downtown Taipei.
Lest you mistake the replica for a mere roadside
attraction, state media released footage of
Chinese troops using it to simulate an invasion.
Needless to say, this is deeply unsettling.
That the Chinese military is actively practicing
an invasion of its small, democratic neighbor
should attract the world’s attention and
outrage.
…And…
it’s not evidence of an imminent plan to
attack.
We know that because it was built nine years
ago.
Yet the failure of our worst fears to materialize
hasn’t prevented the same dire warnings
from being recycled year after year since.
Just a few months ago, for example, U.S. Air
Force General Mike Minihan wrote a memo to
his 50,000 subordinates that began with “I
hope I am wrong.
My gut tells me we will fight in 2025”.
Another ‘Mike’ from the U.S. military
– Admiral Mike Gilday – made headlines
last year for saying he “couldn’t rule
out” a Chinese attack in 2022 or 3.
Each time, the evidence simply accumulates.
Every authoritative prediction or alarmist
headline reinforces the perception that war
is inevitable or even imminent.
“Where there’s smoke, there must be fire.”
But Taiwan has now been “on the brink of
war” for most of a decade.
Which means we’re long overdue for some
reflection.
Sponsored by “China, Actually”, my 6-part
series available only on Nebula.
Let’s start with what we know…
First, few countries have transformed so completely
as China since 1949.
Yet, despite these 74 years of continuous
tumultuous change – during which not even
the written language survived untouched – on
one issue China has been remarkably consistent.
Every leader since Mao has reaffirmed the
importance of unification.
Despite having never governed Taiwan, the
Party defines itself as the rightful heir
to and guardian of Chinese history, culture,
and, more problematically, the Han ethnicity.
America’s involvement in the region and
Taiwan’s growing national identity certainly
add insult to injury, but the mere existence
of another government that claims the label
“Chinese” is already perceived as a threat.
Second, we know that in the last two decades,
China has rapidly modernized its military.
Truthfully, neither the size of its fleet
nor its budget are perfect measures of anything.
Chinese ships are generally smaller and its
budget, easily distorted.
Besides, how does one accurately discount
the abilities of an army that hasn’t fought
a single major war for nearly half a century?
But although experts disagree about the relative
strength of the Chinese and American militaries,
there’s no doubt the gap between them is
shrinking.
What was once a guaranteed U.S. victory is
now uncertain.
Finally, we also, of course, know that – despite
its explicit intent and growing capability
– China hasn’t yet invaded.
The question, and where facts become speculation,
is why not?
One interpretation is that China is waiting
to cross some threshold of tactical superiority.
Once it does – which could be any day now
– war is inevitable.
The advantage of this theory is its simplicity.
When Xi Jinping says Taiwan, quote, “must
and will be reunited with China”, it doesn’t
take a wild imagination to hear “we can
and will invade”.
When he repeatedly mentions the year 2049
as the target for China’s “rejuvenation”,
it’s not outlandish to interpret this as
a hard deadline for unification.
After all, it isn’t as if this increasing
assertiveness is confined to words.
Here’s a timeline of recent Chinese “gray
zone” tactics aimed at Taiwan – coercive
activities that fall somewhere between normal
diplomacy and outright war.
For instance, in 2016 it suspended all communication.
In 2019, its fighter jets flew closer to the
island than they had in the previous two decades.
And the next year, Beijing stopped importing
Taiwanese pineapples, one of its largest industries.
Clearly, proponents of this theory aren’t
hallucinating – tensions are undeniably
growing.
But although intuitive, this theory is not
without its weaknesses.
Namely, if war is inevitable, why give your
opponent a specific timeline?
Generally speaking, politicians prefer to
keep their options open.
Why needlessly impose on yourself a deadline?
At a time when the U.S. and Taiwan are looking
for reasons to increase their defense budgets,
why give them the literal and rhetorical ammunition
they need?
China’s best hope for success would involve
quick, decisive action, giving America little
time to respond.
Yet, not only does China not hide its intentions,
it releases footage of its replica presidential
building online!
If that first theory sees the current moment
as a critical turning point where China is
on the verge of finally following through
on its promises, a second one sees as much
continuity as it does change.
Sure, China has recently become more aggressive.
But this timeline only goes back to 2016,
during which Taiwan has only had one president
and one ruling party.
Now watch what happens when we extend the
timeline to the year 2000.
From then until 2008, Taiwan was led by the
“green” Democratic Progressive Party,
which is skeptical of engagement with China.
The DPP, at that time, inched closer to declaring
independence than it ever has.
…Close enough that, after China protested,
George Bush stepped in to warn the island
not to proceed.
Following this incident, Beijing enacted an
“Anti-Secession Law” in 2005, which made
explicit its longstanding threat to invade
if Taiwan declared independence.
All this changed in 2008, when the DPP lost
to the “blue” Kuomintang, or KMT, which
promotes engagement with China and is strongly
opposed to independence.
For the next eight years, its relations with
China were the warmest they’ve ever been.
The two presidents met, shook hands, and signed
a free trade agreement.
Today, it may feel like a lifetime away, but
less than a decade ago, many laughed at the
idea that China would invade an economy it
was investing billions of dollars in.
Then, in 2016, the DPP returned to power.
While it no longer advocates independence,
it has strengthened its unofficial relationship
with the United States.
In response, China cut off all communication,
banned many Taiwanese imports, and conducted
increasingly elaborate military exercises.
Now, it’s impossible to prove whether China
would’ve become more hostile even if the
KMT had remained in power, but this timeline
certainly suggests a clear relationship between
the Taiwanese government and China’s approach.
This is not at all to blame Taiwan – Beijing
chooses its reactions.
It does, however, suggest a logic to this
reprehensible aggression.
Think of China’s position as a spectrum.
On one side is its ideal outcome – unification.
On the other side are its “red lines”.
Most believe that China would invade today
if Taiwan declared independence.
In between is a range of more and less tolerable
scenarios.
With the KMT in charge, independence is off
the table.
China relaxes, and uses carrots to gently
pull Taiwan toward unification.
When the DPP is elected, China switches to
a coercive “stick” approach to push Taiwan
away from its red lines.
When viewed this way, Xi’s speeches sound
a lot more like threats than announcements.
When he seems to contradict himself by saying,
quote, “We will continue to strive for peaceful
reunification…
but we will never promise to renounce the
use of force.”, you could stress the “force”
part and dismiss the word “peaceful” as
nakedly disingenuous.
After all, China has been disingenuous about
Hong Kong and Xinjiang and the South China
Sea.
You could also do the opposite and ignore
what’s obviously a threat.
But there’s a third possibility: these two
promises aren’t contradictory.
China genuinely means both.
On one hand, the idea of promising not to
use force is seen as a dangerous concession.
Because it’s the only thing preventing Taiwan
from declaring independence, it would forever
close the door to unification.
At the same time, waging an actual war would
be extraordinarily costly.
Taiwan produces roughly 92% of the world’s
most advanced semiconductors.
Nearly a fifth of the Chinese population lives
in the three provinces closest to Taiwan.
And 90% of the world’s largest ships transit
through the Taiwan Strait.
Even if they could take the longer route through
Indonesia, it would increase shipping costs
by an estimated half a billion dollars each
month.
Collectively, a one-year war would reduce
America’s GDP by 5-10% and China’s by
25-35%, according to one study from 2016.
Now, let’s be clear: these are wild guesses.
No one can realistically predict the outcome
of a war between two nuclear powers with any
accuracy.
The only thing we can say with certainty is
that such a conflict would fall somewhere
between absolutely catastrophic and existential.
Xi Jinping’s 2049 milestone for “China’s
national rejuvenation” includes economic
prosperity – something incompatible with
any invasion of Taiwan – whether successful
or not.
So, yes, China does prefer peaceful unification.
Of course it would rather achieve all of its
goals without suffering any of the costs.
Similarly, projecting a willingness to fight
offers many of the benefits of actually fighting
but few of the costs.
‘Toughness’ plays well to a domestic audience.
It appeases a powerful political faction – the
military.
It helps build Xi’s personal image.
It’s an insurance policy against embarrassment
in case of a confrontation.
…And it deters independence!
2049 could be a genuine deadline.
It could also be, as the 100th anniversary
of the PRC, a symbolic placeholder that feels
far away, yet signals conviction, yet is also
vague and non-binding – the perfect political
‘promise’.
Some observers claim Xi has urged the PLA
to, quote, “date to fight”.
But other Chinese speakers argue the phrase
could just as easily mean “dare to struggle”.
At the very least, his choice of words is
deliberately ambiguous.
By definition, deterrence only works when
indistinguishable from actual mobilization.
In other words, it’s impossible to prove
whether China is simply deterring independence
or genuinely preparing for an attack.
Having a larger, stronger military is useful
whether or not it fights.
When taken as a whole, all the evidence proves
definitively is that we simply don’t know
when or if China will invade.
The trouble with this indeterminate, conflicting
“evidence” is that it’s ripe for cherry-picking.
Sometimes this ambiguity is cynically exploited.
The more urgent the threat facing America,
the more resources are directed to the military.
But there are legitimate, or at least, understandable,
reasons, too.
The military’s fundamental, and in fact,
singular mission is to prepare for every contingency,
no matter how unlikely.
The real scandal would be if Admiralty Mike
Gilday did rule out a Chinese attack in 2023.
Or if General Mike Minihan wasn’t anticipating
the worst possible outcome.
Anyone who reads General Minihan’s memo
in full will see that it clearly wasn’t
written for a civilian audience – it uses
Air Force jargon and adopts the tone of a
stern, confident superior.
No one has to be doing their job poorly for
the threat to be exaggerated.
The issue may be that someone is doing their
job.
The problem arises when this mindset escapes
the walls of the Pentagon.
In the media, not only do these warnings lose
their institutional context – the organizational
paranoia that we, the public, demand from
the armed forces – but they carry undue
credibility.
At the end of the day, these are just guesses!
That fact is confirmed by the sheer diversity
of predictions.
Despite this, they carry significant authority.
As one political correspondent wrote, “I
don’t know if or when China will invade
Taiwan…
But I figure that when someone like four-star
Air Force general Mike Minihan… writes…we
should probably sit up and take notice.”
The United States should prepare for an invasion.
The consequences of a potential conflict would
be so devastating that we simply can’t afford
not to take the threat seriously.
After all, Putin’s war in Ukraine demonstrates
that no one’s sober, rational judgment can
be taken for granted.
The challenge is to prepare for war as if
it were inevitable, without succumbing to
a self-fulfilling prophecy.
To train for a sprint, while not losing sight
of the fact that we may be running a marathon.
If conflict is a chronic, not acute challenge,
for example, America would be better off investing
in, not diversifying away, from the Taiwanese
economy, which only makes it more dependent
on China.
U.S.-China tensions are unlikely to dramatically
improve in any lasting way in the foreseeable
future.
Which makes careful management of that relationship
more important than ever.
But it’s precisely because an invasion of
Taiwan may not be guaranteed that we should
take it seriously – our actions may influence
the outcome.
If an invasion isn’t guaranteed, exaggerating
the threat could do more harm than good.
As experts Ryan Hass, Bonnie Glaser, and Richard
Bush point out, while an actual war is hypothetical,
China is already engaged in a psychological
war of attrition.
Contrary to what many Americans assume, no
individual Chinese missile, fighter jet, or
speech provokes much fear in Taiwan.
But cumulatively, China’s objective is to
slowly wear down Taiwan’s will to resist
– to propagate a general sense of uncertainty
and insecurity.
In a 2017 survey, just 41% of the Taiwanese
public believed China would attack if Taiwan
declared independence.
Three years later, that number rose to 61%.
If America’s pessimism is more fatalist
than motivational, it risks doing China’s
work for it.
And finally, if or when we do detect signs
of an imminent attack, one of America’s
first actions will be to notify its allies.
Crying ‘wolf’ today would undermine its
credibility tomorrow.
In the early 2000s, for example, a Chinese
general made headlines for claiming “hundreds”
of U.S. cities would be targeted with nuclear
weapons if America defended Taiwan in a war.
This comment, and others like it, led to panicked
speculation about the true size of China’s
nuclear stockpile.
But this theory is likely wrong.
And this kind of exaggeration does no good
for Taiwan.
I explain why in this episode of “China,
Actually”, which is available only on Nebula.
In that same series, we also explore four
other questions about China – like why most
of the rare earth metals necessary to build
electronics come from one rural town in Inner
Mongolia, and why Chinese censorship is both
more and less strict than we often imagine.
Nebula, the streaming platform built by and
for independent creators, is the only place
you can watch those videos.
There are no ads or sponsors and many videos
are available early.
This one you’re watching now, for instance,
has been available on Nebula since early July.
Nebula is home to dozens of other great Originals
too – like Wendover Productions’ “The
Logistics of X”, and RealLifeLore’s modern
conflicts, explaining the wars we hear about
in the news but rarely have time to truly
understand.
Normally Nebula costs $5 a month.
But you can get it 50% off, for just $2.50
a month, by signing up for a year with the
link on screen or in the description now.